hello everybody and welcome to let's
play candles this is I actually have no
idea what this is I remember downloading
it a while ago but it's just been
sitting in my folder and I don't
remember why but I think I think it's
something interesting so I once said
that it was about another game was as
blind as I could go this is as blind as
I could go because I don't even remember
why I download it and now oh hey look
it's a candle I know it does a torch
just floating there
oh no it's sticking out of the ground I
don't know if this has something to do
with like slender or what-have-you
you're like a little kid woo hi kiddo
Beatrix kiddo
yeah I'm really um confused nice lens
flare hello I hear like a beep shock
thing
oh hello can I Oh hot jump I can
actually jump in a game this is so weird
Wow look at that lens flare oh there's
some more oh man wait what's that what
the heck is that seeing eyes is those
eyes there are those those eyes aren't
they those eyes yep
those look like eyes I'm uh can't go
this way coz there's an invisible wall
let's see what this is no while you've
been away your basement generator must
have run out of fuel thus your house has
been overrun with the dark loving night
imps that scour these parts of the
coastline as you know they usually live
off fish and what they can find in the
forest but they are extremely
territorial so I'm afraid they won't
give up their newfound home easily you
will have to carefully go through each
room fighting candles fighting candles
to scare the IMP subway and finally make
your way to the basement to refuel the
generator with the electricity and main
lights back on
the Imps will surely leave you in your
house in peace sincerely mr. postman PS
you won't be getting any mail before
you've gotten rid of your little
infestation
okay could I could I light a candle
please that's lovely
ha got it so I don't want to I don't
wanna
oh no candle light hi candle light ha Oh
was that what is that what are you oh
your chair oh whoops sorry light point
tonight ah I've never been more
apprehensive about going in a dark room
before oh that's that that's lovely
that's uh that's a good painting to
decorate a house with I'm glad that's
there mm I think I need to get my key to
this door from my bedroom Oh because I
am smart in ha ha well that Hey what I
thought you didn't like the light
why am I'm guessing I'm doing that on
purpose or what ah who lit these candles
huh yeah Westmark bags of stop balls
what was that did I did I die
what happen hello
did uh can you uh tell me what uh
happened there
ah no what I died how who did this to me
tobias danbo lasa Westmark Neil I am at
time
oh that's baloney how did I die does it
just touch the thing and whoops oh okay
whatever you go kamiya house like that
w huh oh it's already lit thank you for
that cuz I have no idea why this yeah I
guess I'm not supposed to touch at all
see you go there get other you will
scamp check it out it's better that's
what I thought
Oh like these things so nothing no
candle in here okay yeah I shouldn't
have gone in there in the first place
jeez ha what's the ha who'd say yo ho ha
I now know why the game is called
candles
Oh No Oh No
ha ok ok no ha ha
what the hell chair you attacked me
jeez don't scare me like that balsa Roni
Oh
oh no no no good good good ah no yeah
that's right yeah yeah let it let what's
get dirty
key ah there are ladies now I can keep
you to myself like this guy I don't like
it at all
I don't like it hello
why is this room go dark who's snuffing
out my candles
who who dumped out my candles let it not
it let it let it who did this
who's I was I'm your though yes what I
thought you did you huh
uh-huh what is that huh oh those aren't
it ah
I sell come on the light mama I'll mess
you up
how is that guy in here it make sense to
the rest of the game but whatever I can
on light a candle what my basement
ah come on come here
come on good nope yeah I thought
whoo so no no no no Suze I've never had
a game it was so dark that I hugged the
walls crawl by ah light light oh no like
light light light
how do I fill this up with gasoline wait
hang on did jingle-jangle
I see it it's jingle jangling how do I
get you to move how do I move you I want
to kiss you ah yeah how why what the
hell how did that do that wait what I'm
moving it just tiniest bit yeah oh this
is totally working man I don't know
what's going on here
I can't like click on it and rotate it I
can't I can't be ok maybe it just is not
much gas and I gotta find some gas or
something I don't know these I don't
know I'm trying to click on things with
they're not not working I'm not working
and I don't want to go back I'm here let
me solve the problem I am an engineer
perfectly trained to handle things all
right okay I guess I gotta uh I don't
know what I gotta do honestly I I'm
assuming that I need like a bucket or
something to transfer oil or fuel how to
know where do I get buckets Oh
what happens if I leave what el okay so
not this is not what I'm not I'm not
supposed to be out here definitely not
okay back inside okay I got it I got I
got if I don't figure out by the time
this episode over which is going to be
pretty soon just um let me know in the
comments below then doing wrong I mean
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying
whoa what's up hang on wow what got what
did I do
how did I do that
oh wait no it is working oh oh oh oh it
is working oh it is uh-huh I thought
something was weird
okay so that didn't work did it
uh-huh can I do the same for these whoa
no okay all right um no no okay
obviously I need some sort of fuel
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
that looks good
all right did it work light yay have a
light what does that mean
I'm not exactly sure what it means
Oh get out one did that do to do that
one I don't know but I'm a lot of time
so I guess um let me know in the
comments below what else I'm supposed to
do because I don't really know once
again I came into this knowing nothing
so please let me know thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always Oh see you in the next video bye